pero saludar entonces en este momento a
nuestro cronista deportivo 'juan
pupiales juana buena mañana de martes
seguimos ampliando esta información para
profundizar en lo que ocurrió este
sábado vamos a conectar con la ciudad de
querétaro para escuchar el testimonio de
l bardo hernández acompañado de su
esposa melissa herrera testigos de lo
que ocurrió en ese encuentro elevando a
melissa gracias por estar con nosotros
cuéntenos qué fue lo que ustedes vieron
cómo comenzó esta batalla y cómo
pudieron salir del estadio
hola qué tal juan hola buenos días pues
fíjate que nosotros estábamos ahí
estamos tenemos balcón una zona familiar
puedes decirlo lo conocemos como la zona
azul en el estadio la corregidora de
querétaro
estábamos viviendo por el minuto 60
aproximadamente
cuando hubo una pelea
digamos típica entre las barras está
estos dos equipos tienen mucho odio
porque el atlas descendió al querétaro y
luego se hizo la primera campaña la usan
una una locura pero los hechos fueron
que en la zona sur del estadio empezó
esta trifulca y aficionados del atlas la
porra que está al sureste del estadio
empezó a salir se empezó a salir sea
justamente las heras que estás pasando a
ir a atacar justamente a ellos entonces
aquí se ve cómo van llegando de pronto
mi esposa y yo detectamos que en la zona
en la que estábamos nosotros iban
pasando por detrás
están las personas de la afición
queretana y van en dirección a una allá
ahí empezó la locura se destaparon las
las partes de la barra de querétaro como
que los laterales del centro de la barra
queretana seguía intacta sin embargo la
del atlas salió por completo de la barra
y todo continuó tanto dentro de la
cancha como fuera del estadio en el
bueno dentro del stand pero el circuito
externo del estadio donde comunican
todas las puertas
ahí hay también varios vídeos que se han
visto así
para nuestra salida pues nosotros vimos
que en la pelea dentro de la cancha
empiezan a migrar a nuestra parte la
zona sur que es la parte baja que será
en la cámara y corre la gente hacia
nosotros entonces nosotros en un acto de
solidaridad buscamos poder ayudar y
había muchos aficionados del atlas que
fue lo que lo que buscamos lo que
quisimos hacer otorgar una una chamarra
y ayudará a subir niños a los palcos
mujeres a los palcos y después ayudó a
calmar a una señora a niños la violencia
estaba completamente exagerada iban por
cualquier punto rojo y pues no tocaba
más que claro más que el ser humano si
ayudar triste esta situación elevando
los saludo muy buen día gracias por
estar con nosotros en deportes de
directo américa y también le quiero
preguntar entonces algo que también
hemos visto en muchas redes sociales
también hay medios de comunicación que
han reportado esto y es que si realmente
hubo heridos usted pudo ver el cuerpo
sin móviles a lo mejor como como los
vídeos que circularon en las redes
sociales que nos puede decir al respecto
es correcto de nuestra salida pues al
estar ayudando nos tocó pasar por el
circuito y
no alcanzamos a ver estamos un poquito
lejos pero se veían ya bastantes
personas siendo atendidas por los
cuerpos de seguridad
esa es la pregunta que todo el mundo se
hace ustedes creen desde lo que ustedes
pudieron haber visto a melissa le bardo
que este ataque solamente dejó heridos o
tenemos también que lamentar fallecidos
es difícil de decir porque pues no no se
dice con certeza pero lo que muestran
las redes sociales es que si hay muertos
y ustedes no sabemos a ciencia cierta
pero lo que sí es cierto es que
no
hubo hubo peleas hubo agresiones
exageradas
pero pues no nos tocó dar un veredicto
porque
no pertenecemos a la parte de salud ni
nada por el estilo y gracias a dios no
tuvimos ningún afectado o cercano allí
en mexico en su país cuál es el
sentimiento respecto a este episodio que
está dando tristemente la vuelta al
mundo
de desafiliar al equipo
pero pero en general las personas que
estamos viéndolo desde lejos que no
tenemos ningún familiar herido en nada
sentimos una profunda tristeza yo
trabajo en un colegio y pues ese es el
tema el tema ese fue el tema de ayer
todas las personas preguntándonos eso
entre los amigos que estábamos en el
estadio comentando lo lo triste que se
siente de hecho estar ahí fue algo muy
difícil o sea es una impotencia de ver
un montón de peleas de la gente que está
pateando a otra gente que está en el
piso y no se puede no tiene cómo
protegerse y no poder hacer nada más que
esperar claro el examen fue fue una
impotencia muy fuerte y se siente un
vacío en el vientre un muy feo entonces
pienso que yo siento que en general es
una tristeza muy grande no y también
lamentable melissa elevarlo y juán que
los niños como usted trabaja en un
colegio tengan que ver esto que ejemplo
le estamos dando a nuestros niños a
nuestros adolescentes algo tan bonito
como el deporte que pues evidentemente
hay equipos contrarios pero todo tiene
que estar desde el respeto juan así es
elevar de melissa muchísimas gracias por
este testimonio aquí en directo américa
seguimos obviamente muy pendientes a lo
que ocurra con este episodio que
seguramente del cual seguiremos hablando
melissa elevado gracias muy buen día un
abrazo